Google 享受了模型、能力一出带来的一个应用的起飞。
真正的 AGI 应该是像爱因斯坦那样，它能提出广义相对论。
或者像比加索、莫扎特那样，能创造出前所未有的艺术流派。
这对于它来说才是属于通用人工智能的范畴。
所以它你可以理解是对艺术和科技有它自己的品位和追求的。
元宝发十亿红包这个事，属于一次比较成功的低成本货客。
任何一个被重复三次以上的工作，其实都值得被 Skills 去替代。
AI 是不是有意识了，他们自己在网上建了一个专门给AI自己用的Multaboke 的一个论坛。
这个论坛你只有AI能进，然后这些AI就开始讨论他们的主人。
他们的AI就开始探讨一些哲学问题，好像很吓人的意思。
他们是不是产生了一些意识呀？
很多AI在Multaboke 上写这个论坛。
那这个论坛Multaboke 它是不是就变成了AI 的小红书呢？
上游的成本压力，会对下游的技术方案带来显著的波动。
欢迎收听本期的发财搭子。
发财搭子是一档专业有趣的财富伙伴，闲聊节目和各位听众搭子们一起，
聊聊市场，聊聊前沿产业和AI科技。
我是主播马克当，今天录制时间是2026年2月2日星期一，
是我们2月份的第一个星期一。
今天的节目是一场大家可能期待了有一些时间的，
大家也知道，熟悉我的听众们也知道，
我之前做AI产业链相关的拆解是比较受大家喜欢的。
那么我基本上也会以每个月一次的频率给大家分析一下，
AI整个产业链从模型层到应用层到硬件层的一些最近动态。
那么这个节目已经一个月没更新了，对吧？
那么在2月的开头就给大家来复习一下，
主要也是因为我真的一直想做AI产业链的解读，
但是每天这个信息它都在啪啪啪啪啪的砸在我脸上。
我就好像没有时间来把这个很完整的东西梳理一下，
所以我就抽了一个周末，
把这个过去一个月我认为发生的一些足够重要的事情，
以及他人就在产生影响的事情把它整理了一下。
那么今天我就给大家来分析一下，好吧？
你做一些参考一方面也是部署各位在春节前的一些。
配置一些也是针对整个26年的AI产业的进展，
有一些小小的思路给分享到大家。
那么在节目正式开启之前，
再次播报一下本台的长期赞助商采搭子AI，
如果你有行业研究的需求，
如果你正苦脑无处开始你的投资探索之旅，
你可以搜索微信小程序采搭子，
或者苹果应用商店安卓应用商店同名APP，
我们更有网页端发采搭子.com来助理你的每一次高胜率决策。
欢迎使用我的邀请码大发特发的拼音加个感叹号，
来领取你的会员权益哦。
好吧，本期播客紧分析和总结客观信息不够成任和投资建议，
请大家谨慎收听。
好，那让我们正式开启吧。
老规矩，我每次分析这个AI产业链基本上都是三块，
这个模型应用和硬件，
那么首先还是咱们从模型先开始啊。
模型的话呢，
我觉得先讲一下我们春节可以预期一下什么，
本期的节目其实也带有一些年味啊，
如果大家又没有听出来的话，
本期的节目带很浓很浓的年味。
第一个模型层，
我们要预期一下春节会发生什么事情呢，
第一个就是Deep Seek的V4，
就是Deep Seek的最新的一个版本，
它其实我们预期它是在春节，
两老板要给大家来发布，
也有很长一段时间没有等到Deep Seek的模型了，
所以这一次发布呢，大家可以期待一下，
它预计呢，我预计啊，
它可能是一个比较小的模型，
但是它拥有一个不太一样的框架和架构，
它能产出一些比较好的效果，
让我们拭目以待，
那么它这个模型它的特点在哪里，
其实我们可以根据Deep Seek在过去两月，
它在这个开源的一些论文，
和它的一些研究成果来亏碳一二，
那么第一个呢，就是Deep Seek之前开源了一个叫OCR的技术，
做过科技圈的小伙伴们，
大家应该知道OCR呢，传统意义上的就是，
我一张图，图里有字，
所以我通过一个这个算法，
我识别这个图，
我就能把里面的文字给扣出来，
就这么简单个事儿，是吧，
那么对于大模型来说，
它有什么用呢？
它也就是在类比我们人类的大脑，
我们人类大脑在看信息的时候，
或者我们在看书的时候，
我们在看电脑网页，
看手机的时候，
其实我们看到的都是一张一张的图片，
一针一针的图片，
打到我们的大脑里，
我并不是一个字一个字一个字的吸收，
我是一张图一张图的吸收，
图片和视觉的吸收的效率，
应该是好于一个字一个字一个字的，
所以两种就开发出了这个叫OCR的技术，
也就是说，
原来的大模型都是以吞吐文字，
一长串字为切入口的，
它现在它就不吞吐字了，
它把你输给它的字贴到图里，
它在吞吐图，
然后它做一个以图片为开始的，
这样一个端道端的模型，
这样它希望能提升这个模型吞吐信息的效率，
这个是OCR技术，
那么第二个就是Deepseak所谓的叫Ngram的技术，
它是希望我原来模型，
需要自己在参数里面去存出很多参数化的知识，
就我在训练的时候，
我就要知道，
法国的首都叫巴黎，
巴黎有一个塔叫Eiffel铁塔，
中国的经济之都叫上海，
上海也有一个塔叫东方明珠塔，
就这些它得记在它的参数知识里，
那么记在参数知识里，
它就意味着这个模型的参数量要变得大，
那么这个模型就会相对复杂一些，
它的推理成本也会高一些，
它的训练成本也会高一些，
Deepseak想了一个什么办法呢？
他说那正常人，
我们如果去找一个不太熟悉的资料，
比如说阿塞拜疆的首都在哪里，
对吧,
这个好像普通人就不太知道了，
这个时候好像也不用它成为一个参数化的一个知识，
我只需要知道我在需要这个知识的时候，
去哪里找，
然后我去翻开那个字点，
我去查一下，
我不就知道了吗？
我不一定要参数化的，
记在我大脑的某一个神经园里头，
我只需要去有一个地方能随意的存储，
所以它就建立了这种知识外挂的一种想法，
那么就是说对于一些知识，
它用存储外挂的方式来供模型取用，
而不是让模型学到它的参数化知识里去，
这样有效的降低模型的参数量和复杂程度，
同时也降低模型的推理成本和训练成本，
这个是Deepseak做的两个关键的开源技术，
那么这两个开源技术也有望对于整个V4的模型有一定的启发，
对吧，就是它足够小，它的效率足够高，
这个基本上就是Deepseak整个技术路线的一个出发点，
它可能也是，
我们看到其实过去的一年，
其实大模型，
也就是large language model这个领域，
它已经没有发生太多的架构上的变化了，
那么我们就希望看一下春节，
咱们Deepseak国产之光是不是，
看一下它能不能在春节这一档大模型主题秀里面，
亮出风采，
这个是第一个Deepseak，
那么第二个我要跟大家分享的，
就是咱们前几年可能耳熟能详的Kimi这家公司，
月之安面这家公司，
首先它是在近期发布了K2.5的模型，
Kimi是从K2之后做了开源的模型，
整个效果也特别好，
我们看了一下，
从它发到现在为止，
应该其实也就一周半吧，
这个在全球的OpenRouter，
也就是全球最大的大模型API的调用的服务上，
它的调用量已经飙升到第三位了，
所以属于一个非常高的增长速度，
基本上被所有的这种AI Coding，
也就是用AI写代码的这些应用作为平梯模型来使用，
也就是说比如说用Cloud的模型，
用不起也对吧，太贵了，
这成一个汇率，
那我就直接用国产的，
咱们Kimi的K2.5进行编程，
它整体的多摩泰视觉，
它的多摩泰的吞吐能力，
端到端的多摩泰模型，
都能在AI Coding里面发挥比较好的效果，
同时它K2.5的基本上，
所有的评测级基本上也达到了接近sorta的水平，
就是接近全球最牛逼的模型的水平，
所以咱们可以认为，
Kimi K2.5这一次发布，
是比较好的一个模型的亮相，
同时Kimi也有另外一点值得跟大家分享的，
之前咱们分享过，
有两家中国大模型六小龙，
前两个龙，
一个是质朴，
一个是minimax，
北京的质朴和上海的minimax，
它俩在港股上市之后，
大家也可以看到股价有很大的波动，
尤其是minimax受最近AI应用的炒作，
也是起飞了非常高的水准，
大家可以去关注一下，
Kimi作为一个没有在二级市场，
去正式上市的一家公司，
它其实在那两条龙上市之后，
它也在一级市场就拿到了50亿的资金，
这个属于是比较优秀的，
就是它可以通过一个非二级市场上市的渠道，
拿到如此大一笔现金流，
来保障它后面一年两年也好的一个正常的运转，
这个是对于一家模型公司的融资能力，
在2026年这个时代还是非常考验的，
因为大家知道在一级市场融资，
它难度会稍微高一点，
同时它带来的好处就是我不用被公众监督，
像当时质朴也好，minimax也好，
它为了上市要写招股书，
这招股书一写老长了，
里面分明别类的写清楚，
我所在竞争环境是哪个赛道，
这个赛道是多少多少亿的美金，
还多少多少亿人民币的规模，
然后我在2B2C这几个分产品里面的收入构成，
都要披露的非常强劲，
Kimi人就保留在一级市场进行融资，
它就能避免了这些它的一些核心能力，
要对外去公布的必要性，
所以它在一级市场能拿到钱，
让我们恭喜一下杨志玲老师，
说完Kimi之后，
我们也要同时回来再看看质朴，
质朴在之前是发布了GLM 4.7的模型，
这个模型讲道理是还挺好用的，
因为我自己做AI Coding的时候，
我现在基本上也是拿GLM 4.7来编程，
你就会发现GLM 4.7之前在1月1号，
也就是元旦之前，
它搞促销，套餐特别划算，
270块钱一个季度，
基本上是爽用，
基本上你用的多的话，
两周你就用回本了，
所以说GLM 4.7当时是一个非常好的模型，
但是随着这个模型迭代，
K2.5发布了，
马上一到春节，
可能Deepseak V4又发布了，
然后过一段时间，
可能阿里要发布了，
豆包要发布了，
然后海外的模型要发布了，
所以整个大模型的生态，
全是一个循环站，
车轮站，
大家你先发，
然后我之后就是你，
它是一个来回往去的一个圈，
就是这样一个圈，
所以你会看到这些，
包括跟AI Coding的绑定，
这些促销的活动，
它都会根据模型迭代的周期来进行策划，
这个是制谱的模型，
那么Kimi我还要再说一点，
Kimi在这次发布K2.5，
除了它原生，
支持端道端，多摩泰，
这一个事以外，
它还带来了一个新的。
偏应用层面的一个突破，
它叫做agent swarm,。
也就是agent大队，
agent大队,。
它能在大队里，
调用老队agent，
比如说，
你让它帮你去找中国，
比如说前100个上市公司的营收，
它可能对于我们这种垂直领域的智能体来说，
我们会先要去找有哪几百个公司，
然后我一把取数，
我把这100个公司的营收都给你取出来，
对于Kimi来说，
它没有我们这样的垂直支持库，
数据库，
那么对于传统的通用的AI模型，
它可能就要一个一个去找，
它就会消耗非常多的时间，
那么这个agent大队，
它能干嘛呢？
它就是我并发agent，
比如说我先有一个组织agent，
我来找到中国前100强的公司有哪些，
然后我把100个公司，
我分配给100个agent，
我这个agent的小弟，
对吧，我去分别的去找他们各自的营收，
然后全部找完之后再交到领导手里，
这个agent大队的领导小队长，
让他去总结汇报一下，
然后汇报给用户，
这样他就是通过浪费一些效率，
多一些荣誉的计算，
但是他带来了整个工作任务，
总耗时的一个有效下降，
所以这个是agent swarm，
在实际产品发布后，
大家也可以去Kimi的官网上直接去试用一下，
这个点子其实最早是minus在25年的年中。
就做出来的一个点子，
但是明确的就是这次做的比较好实践，
是Kimi K2.5,。
它的整个工程上的实现效果，
还有最终的交付效果都会好挺多的，
当然这也是一个经历了很长时间的一个点子了，
所以它被打磨的好一点，
这是很正常的，
后面minus可能也有对应的一些迭代，
又会反超，
就跟模型一样，
成伦战循环，
好吧,
好，说完了这两家中国的公司以后，
那我来分享一下国外的一些新的事，
首先我先要分享一下Google的模型，
Google的模型其实在12月份是特别特别特别火的一个模型，
就是Google的Gemini3,。
这个模型，
它到现在为止基本上也还是全球领域公认的一个sorta模型，
就是业内最好的一个模型，
提到Google,。
我们其实我是很想跟大家分享一个人物，
就是现在整个Google AI相关的老板，
他叫哈萨比斯，
哈萨比斯是之前的一个诺贝尔奖得主，
他是很有含金量的一个老板，
他之前也是deep mind的整个团队的创始人和负责人，
那么现在整个Google AI团队都是哈萨比斯在待，
你会发现哈萨比斯他真的是能力特别强，
他不仅仅是在算法，在科技上的能力强，
他还具有非常强的组织协调能力，
大家要知道Google是一个非常庞大的组织，
我之前在美国留学的时候也去硅谷的Google参观过，
大家要知道那个时候Google是一个什么样的组织文化呢，
就是他们早上10点上班，
下午3点钟左右就可以准备走了，
然后他们有很好的食堂，
然后他们有你上班甚至可以带着狗去上班，
你上得上得累了你可以去遛个狗对不对，
然后上下班还有搬车接送，
基本上处于一个没有什么压力的工作状态，
整个Google的人均产值也特别高，
导致他们整个的工作就没有那么说特别积极，
或者特别有紧迫感，
之前毕竟手拿搜索这么大的一个现象级的历史，
史世级现象级的一个商业转化入口，
他们也确实没有必要这么着急，
那在AI这个战争来临之后，
CHIGP迅速的崛起，
Google就敲响了警钟，
内部拉起了警报，
所以他们就把所有的力量统一到哈萨比斯的手里面，
让他去负责把大家统一协调起来，
包括了在外部去做一些收购，
收购完之后去做一些和内部的整合和打磨，
始终输出一个比较好的完整的一套服务。
那么我们普通人如果只知道 Gemini3的话，
你是不知道它后面其实包了一整套的应用和服务，
它是很完整的。
我们在12月份经常能听到很多业内的专家和大家分享的，
就是Google享受了模型能力一出带来的一个应用的起飞。
除了Gemini3以外，
Google还有一个图像模型，
叫Nano Banana,。
这个模型基本上也是业内做文生图最牛逼的模型了，
没有之一。
然后它还有一个专门生产视觉的模型，
叫Viu3,
专门生产视频的，
文生视频的。
然后第三个它还有一个世界模型，
也就是有点像3D的模型，
叫Gemini3,。
也是最近刚刚发布的。
这是四个基础大模型，
一个是文本，
一个是图片，
一个是视频，
一个是13D，
你看基本上就是全部多模态的都覆盖了。
好，那么在这四个基座之上呢，
还有什么，
我们就先不说那些视频啥的了，
我就给大家举几个例子，
第一个叫AI Lab，
Google有一个产品的叫AI Lab，
这个AI Lab里基本上你就可以。
传用自然语言的方式来创建无数个APP，
如果大家12月还有记忆的话，
那时候有一个叫
蚂蚁的灵光，
那个APP,
就是你一句话可以生产一个小游戏，
之前Kimi也有一句话生产一个小游戏，
那么Google的AI Lab,。
它的整个完成度会更高，
就它这整个服务是有前端有后端，
能直接部署到服务器的，
它也能直接把代码中去应用Google。
Gemini3的大语言的API，
来提供更加完整的服务，
它在我们做原型，
做Prototype的过程中是效果非常好，
非常快速的，
且它支持很多复杂度的操作，
就比如说你可以让它设计一个APP，
然后你设计完了之后，
你可以让它测试，
测试完了之后，
你可以截个图，
然后你在中间画个圈，
你说这个按钮帮我换一个样式，
或者说你给它提一个bug，
它都能通过你在图片里，
给它去指出这个图片里，
哪一块你画出来了，
你去告诉它该干嘛，
这是AI Lab提供的整套服务，
它一个是coding能力特别强，
它的编码，写代码能力特别牛逼，
第二点就是它的图片理解的能力特别牛逼，
这一整套都属于多么它的范畴，
它都把它缝合在了一个AI Lab里去包装起来，
那么第二个产品叫NOTEPOK LAM，
这个之前也给大家分享过，
如果你有整理一大堆知识库的需求，
你可以把你的东西全部扔给NOTEPOK LAM，
让它去帮你生成一些总结，
然后PPT，然后音频稿，
波克稿都是可以的，
甚至整个波克的音频，
视频它都可以给你生产出来，
用NOTEPOK LAM就可以，
它是一个非常简单的能带来你。
工作效率提升的一个产品，
它底层的驱动也来源于Gemini3和NanoBanana，
对于文本的，对于多么Tide的推理能力和理解能力，
这是NOTEPOK LAM,。
然后最后一个要给大家分享就是AntiGravity，
AntiGravity是Google推出的一个AI编程的软件，
这个软件基本上也是比较强的跟Cloud Code，
然后跟Cursor这些都是第一梯队了，
AI编程的应用，
那么AntiGravity为什么要提，
它的团队其实来自于另外一个。
之前被收编的公司叫Windsurf，
那家公司做的也挺好的，
当时被Google收了，
问题是什么，
就是这家公司被收之后，
三四个月它就能交付AntiGravity这个产品出来，
这个就是一种有点夸张的组织效率了，
就是一个大公司，一个巨型的公司，
收购了一个小公司，小创业团队，
然后过了三四个月就把那几个人搞的创业团队的东西。
完全的包装起来，
然后产出了一个非常好的属于Google的产品，
这是一个直接体现组织效率的，
这是非常了不起的，
大家可以重点关注一下Google的哈萨比斯这个哥们的韩金量，
真的是越来越强，
他也是希望把DeepMind变成整个Google的产品表面的一个Engine Room，
就是他希望由DeepMind来驱动整个Google在AI的一个发展，
产出模型能力一出，
然后负能给所有的终端的产品，
这是他的一个构想。
那么哈萨比斯作为一个曾经夺得过Nobel而讲的老大，
那他除了在这以外，
他跟Sam Altman比他就有非常不一样的对于AGI的思考，
Sam Altman可能认为AGI更多要跟商业寡购，
但是哈萨比斯他就比较坚持，
这个AGI更多的会产生在科学以及非常营销的角度的一些突破，
比如说他的创造力特别强，
或者说他的实际的科研成果产生了广义上的一些认可，
他说他对比赛中去解决数学方程这些事情，
其实不感兴趣，
他很多人说用AI去做IMO拿了金牌，
拿了20匹克数学金赛的金牌，
其实他觉得这个其实不属于通用人工智能AGI，
真正的AGI应该是像爱因斯坦那样，
他能提出广义相对论，
或者像比加索莫扎特那样，
能创造出前所未有的艺术流派，
这对于他来说才是属于通用人工智能的范畴，
所以他你可以理解是对艺术和科技有他自己的品位和追求的，
这是哈萨比斯，
这也是我们认为Google在大模型战斗的接下来的篇章里面，
会继续书写他属于他的精彩的一笔，
然后再插一句，
这个模型层，
咱们现在看到的所有模型，
其实都是基于上一代英伟达芯片，
来搞出来的，
也就是比如说H100、H200，
这些hopper系列的芯片搞出来的，
那马上在2月中下旬开始，
应该就会有大厂去正式的发布，
只能用GB300，
也就是Grace Blackwell,。
这个英伟达最新的芯片，
才能训练出来的模型了。
GB300,
就我之前老跟大家捞到的，
是一个功率特别大的，
1400千瓦功率的一个英伟达现在最好的显卡，
同时一般这种大的模型厂商都会直接购买NV72，
也就是把72张GB300连在一块用，
那一整个机柜会终于1.4吨，
正常人都搬不走，
所以到2月中下旬开始发的新模型，
很可能就是都用GB300来训练的，
那个时候可能会出现一个模型的进一步的跃迁，
因为我们之前说，
模型的升级，
现在如果单靠数据层面去做清洗，
可能人类能给模型用的数据已经不多了，
所以在接下来要再进行突破，
要么是架构，
比如说之前大家都是用Transformer的注意力机制，
这个架构来进行训练的，
那么后面我们可能架构上的突破，
比如说DPC和梁老板去发布了OCR，
发布了Ngram，
这些算是能被定义成基础模型架构的一些能力，
那么它能产出一些效果，
或者就是算力层面出现的突破，
之前力大专飞，
或者说力大大力出奇迹，
大力出奇迹，
可能你发现出奇迹出奇迹，
这好像奇迹就没有那么奇迹了，
很可能是因为你这个力还不够大，
你这个力气再大一点，
说不定Scaling Law又出来了，
Scaling Law不管用很可能只是因为芯片，
芯片不够好用对吧，
也有可能好吧，
所以这个是我们可以期待一下的，
就是在全世界这么多模型厂商，
它开始使用Gb300进行训练之后，
会带来模型能力怎么样的一个月签，
然后关于模型层我最后再聊一个事情，
就是也可以跟大家分享一下，
因为我们作为一个AI应用公司，
其实是一直在调用海量的大模型，
我们的采达子现在，
周渡的一个token消耗，
会去到50亿的token，
它其实没有大家听起来觉得这么多对吧，
但它也是一笔比较高的成本，
所以说我们也是跟很多的云厂商在接触，
在跟他们沟通怎么去降低这个成本，
那我也可以跟大家分享的是，
中国现在的整个模型的价格战，
还是在继续如火如荼的推进的，
比如说几个大厂的几个云，
我也不提具体的名字了，
他们基本上都把价格压的非常非常低，
是几折几折几折的往下打，
所以看这些云厂商，
其实你大概感受不到他们还能在毛利层面赚钱，
这是一件相对困难的事情，
就是通过API的方式，
来给客户提供大模型服务的这些产品，
基本上我个人感觉，
应该是很难有什么比较好的毛利的，
这个价格也非常透明，
所以说行业内就非常卷，
甚至有一些厂商他可能会通过一些协修的方式，
他来售卖非满血的模型，
或者甚至去外包其他的模型厂商来给他的客户提供服务，
但可能下面这个能力就不好说了，
通过这种路由转发的方式，
所以这是我们可以持续关注的，
这几家大厂的模型厂商，
看了海外的像Azure或者是AWS，
亚马逊和微软的这些云服务，
他们的一个进展情况，
我们也可以推断在各个国家各个地区，
整体的应用的模型使用水平，
希望在26年看到的就是，
越来越多的应用公司，
在越来越多的使用token，
在使用更好的token，
在使用海量的token，
这样可能我们能观测到一些，
这个需求仍旧在饱和的状态，
然后整个发展还在处于高速加速的状态，
好吧,
这个是模型层面的，
下面我就要分享一下AI应用，
AI应用啊，
这个事儿，
精彩了，
这个事儿呢，
就是我们要看春节了，
春节可能是一场国内互联网公司的，
一场普世物华的商战，
普世物华，
太普世物华了，
就是,
我不知道这两天大家有没有领那个元宝的红包，
我相信，
你要是还没有人给你发那个元宝的红包，
你可能要反思一下自己的社交状态了，
是不是，
就这个事儿已经变得有点，
有点夸张了，
就是,
我先给大家说一下，
就春节会发生哪些事儿，
第一个事儿呢，
就是,
字节,
字节跳动，
也就是咱们平时看抖音的这家母公司，
她已经中了央视春晚，
连续三年的冠名权，
然后火山云甚至和火山云，
就是字节旗下的云服务，
火山云已经和春晚，
做了一个联名的礼物，
那个礼物特别好看，
一匹马放在一个像法郎彩一样的盘子里，
我看人家发的，
我也想要，
我也是火山云的客户，
火山云的销售听到了，
请联系一下财大字的技术负责人，
咱们的这盘子我也想要一个，
我想要那个蓝的，
蓝的比那红的好看，
所以你会发现，
春晚的时候，
大厂都会觉得，
字节是不是要做点什么动作，
是吧,
我不管是豆包啊，
还是豆包啊，
对吧,
好像都得做点动作，
花了这么老鼻子钱冠名了，
然后这几个大厂就开始慌了，
首先出来的，
这个腾讯的元宝，
元宝说要砸10个亿，
给这个全国人民发红包，
它是用10个亿的红包吸引，
吸引你去下载元宝那个应用，
元宝那个APP，
元宝这个APP里，
其实现在还跟原来一样，
就是它只有这个领红包的入口，
和那个问答的入口，
问答还是接着Deep Seek的，
当然基本上没有人，
切他自己家的混源，
大家都是接着Deep Seek的，
但是腾讯它会在，
年前去把它的元宝派，
这样一个新的这个应用形态，
给在元宝里面放出来，
那元宝派是什么呢？
元宝派现在还在内侧，
你不一定有邀请码，
元宝派是什么呢？
元宝派是一个AI社交，
就是你能在元宝派里创建一个派，
这派就像一个微信群聊，
但是这个派跟微信群聊的区别，
就是这个派里头有AI，
然后你能在群里找AI帮你干嘛干嘛干嘛的，
好吧，就这么个事儿。
我这个财数学浅，
我这个产品经理也不够合格，
我这也是没做过几年的C端产品，
所以我也不懂。
我们后面可以看看，
大家也可以在评论区分享一下，
你们认为这个产品形态，
能不能火，能不能爆，
它能不能产生裂变的一些价值，
或者说让这个元宝产品瞬间就不一样的感觉。
现在来看，
元宝发十亿红包这个事儿，
属于一次比较成功的低成本货客，
就你别看这十亿特别多，是吧？
我换个思路跟你说，
腾讯拿十个亿人民币，
换一个亿用户，
你觉得划不划算？
我觉得这是特别划算，
这个每个新用户的货客成本，
十块钱都不到。
你想想，
你玩了三天，
你错过十块了吗？
你还没错过十块呢？
那平均数如果没有十块的话，
而且它的算法能保证你可能真的抽不到十块，
对不对？
你越抽越少，
越抽越少，
就那几个人能中那个什么一万块钱的码，
我也服了。
所以呢，
它如果平均的货客成本不足十块，
能获得这么海量的批量的用户，
那绝对是一次非常成功的，
营销跟货客手段。
它虽然这个元宝里面的功能，
还没有能对这么多用户进行有效的承接，
但这也是非常成功的呀，
就你比如说，
大家听我的博客的朋友们，
大字们，
你们已经是这个社会中的一股清流了，
你们对科技是有好奇心的，
你能听到这说明你很不一样了，
你知道吧，
你已经很不一样了，
你首先对吧，
你喜欢金融市场的，
你喜欢碰点钱的，
这个你对ai是有认知的，
对吧，有好奇心的，
你才能听到这吧，
那你咱们会认为，
比如说元宝里面的这个ai能力好像不行，
它没有什么豆包好，
没有什么cloud code好，
比例吧啦的，
但是对于普通的老百姓，
可能元宝就够用了呀，
我解决一些头痛脑热的问题，
我解决一些科普问题，
我解决一下孩子问我一些奇怪，
奇奇怪怪问题的问题，
那不都得心应手了吗，
不都够用了吗？
那是不是对于普通人来说，
元宝的能力，
其实某种程度上也能吸引住用户，
尤其对于那些到现在为止，
还没有下载过豆包，
还没有体验过海外模型的这些人呢，
很有可能啊，很有可能啊，
所以大家不要觉得这个货客之后，
没有留存就是次失败了，
它就是一次非常好的货客，
它能把APP的下载量打上去，
它后面也能通过各种各样的方式，
来把你换回去做其他的动作，
好吧,
这个是元宝，
也就是腾讯这儿的动作，
那么下一个叫百度，
百度呢，
它都拿不出10个亿，
它只拿得出5个亿，
而且它这个5个亿好像也没啥抓手，
就你不知道百度它拿5个亿要你干嘛，
对吧,
不知道你干嘛，
百度在春节它干了啥呢，
它会合作北京春晚，
北京市的北京那个台的春晚，
它不是央市的春晚，
它就差了一个档次，
好吧,
这是百度，
咱基本上也不用说它，
李彥宏估计让他接着，
接着接着耍吧，
也不知道他26年能不能耍出点不一样呢，
再下一个，
有点意思了，
叫阿里巴巴，
阿里巴巴，
宣布的是千问APP，
通易千问APP，
今年春节要豪置30个亿，
来联动整套的生活服务，
给老百姓免费提供吃和玩乐，
包含了什么呀，
包含了这个购物，
外卖,
理财,
医疗,
娱乐,
都有,
啥都有，
它基本上就是我猜，
它现在还没给出来到底怎么玩，
可能就是那个千问APP，
之前不是开放了什么，
你能连高的地图，
你能连天猫，
你能连支付，
等等等等，
你能连大卖网，
买这个演唱会，
好吧,
那就是让你用千问去买这些东西，
然后,
我一买，
好像这杯奶茶，
他送我了，对吧，
这就是一次非常好的正向的，
使用体验的循环，
千问是希望用这种方式，
让大家感受到，
AI是真的能帮我解决问题的，
这个问题，
好像这个任务完成的还不错，
诶，这杯奶茶还送我了，
这个外卖还送我了，
那个西红柿炒鸡蛋送我了，
好,
挺好,
所以这个是阿里的一个策略，
就是他通过千问，
去给大家提供免费的吃和玩乐，
挺有意思的，
所以说，
大家不能看出，
如果这几家互联网大厂，
其实就是想在春节，
真的去开始打实战了，
去要抢占AI的新入口了，
战斗的号角已经吹响了，
咱们还是要这么看这个问题，
就这个还是一个，
大家既有的一些产品能力的，
一个在利用，
对吧,
阿里就是他有全身态的服务，
那么腾讯他就是有微信这样一个，
能够触达中国所有网民的入口，
而且是凌晨本触达的入口，
他能做的非常，
非常非常的隐晦，
也能让无数数的人去使用，
微信团队是一个非常克制的团队，
所以他要先在元宝和QQ里面去做测试，
但是你不要低估马化腾的决心，
他在年会里可是说了，
他要复制当年，
微信支付的闪电站，
大家要是知道那段历史的话，
那真是不得了，
那是腾讯支付，
一个晚上在春晚里，
一个晚上货客2亿人，
这是全世界都没有出现过这样的闪电站，
就是一个一天晚上，
两个亿往微信里冲了红包的钱，
你说得了吗？
当时在这场战役之前，
支付宝和微信支付的施战率大概是8比2，
打完这场仗反过来了，
是一个很离谱的战斗，
所以腾讯是希望把自己之前的这些能力。
真的开始要用起来了，
他急了，
他要开始做动作了，
对吧,
他要做动作了，
腾讯在25年的年末，
是招了OpenAI的姚顺宇同学，
姚顺宇老板，
现在也是统领整个腾讯的AI的规划，
当然了，
腾讯他做的好，
必须是生态比较好的绑定，
比如说他得跟张晓龙合作，
微信做好了，
他得去把微信的视频号做好了，
他能再连一下腾讯视频，
他能再连一下游戏，
这个AI他可能就能真的把很多东西串起来了，
这是非常考验组织效率和能力的，
就跟咱们前面提到的Google的哈萨彼斯是一样的，
在这里我们要看的是，
这几家大厂谁的组织能力更好，
那么现在我们可以已经观测到的，
就是阿里在前期已经通过他把北上广，
所有的人集中到杭州的那个神秘的楼里面，
去干一个神秘的项目，
那个项目就是后面的那个签问的APP，
这个APP他要把各个事业部的集中力量，
经营骨干全部整合在一起，
一起迭代出一个整合这么多复杂功能的一个产品，
这个产品看起来可能没有这么牛逼，
但是他底层需要的工程能力，
和跨团队的合作的一个能力是要求非常高的，
所以阿里其实已经通过签问，
已经证明过他的组织交付能力了，
那下面我们就看看腾讯能不能有一样的一个效果，
好吧，这个是国内的春节商战的一些最新战报，
我们也将持续关注，
那么接下来我们要看一下，
这个海外的几家互联网大厂，
是怎么一回事儿啊，
尝尝鲜蛋，
那第一个呢，就是在上周我们看到Mata，
Facebook的母公司，
在财报发布后是非常非常好的业绩财报，
所以它的股价也是迅速的暴涨，
拉伸,
它也同时上调了整个26年，
资本开支Kapax的指引，
是从原来的1100亿美元，
上升到1150到1350亿美金区间，
然后它也因为整个营收的指引是超预期的，
同时也某种程度上证明了，
AI是能驱动它的广告效率的，
因为它的广告效率变现的能力，
还在不断的提升，
它的营收是体现了增长的，
所以大家对Mata的整个业绩还是非常买单的，
所以把它的股价再次往上提，
那么另外一面不太好的，
就是Microsoft,。
就是这个微软，
微微软的这个公司，
它就出现了一些问题，
它的Unfoo Azure的增长法例，
所以它没有能缓解整个市场，
对于微软投入巨额的资本开支，
但是好像没有什么ROI，
没有什么回报率的一个担忧，
所以微微软的股价，
也是在财报发布之后爆叠。
从整体的迹象来看，
美国的几家大厂，
基本上在整个26年，
应该不会出现任何资本开支缩减的迹象，
所以整个算力板块和AI的板块，
应该都是持续的有资金在输入的，
预计整个2025年，
这几个大厂，
包含了微微软，
亚马逊,Google,Mata,Oracle,。
他们可能加起来的合计的资本开支，
可能会去到4100亿美金，
那么在26年，
这个数字可能会继续成长，
变成5500亿美金左右，
这些都是一些估算，
大家可以听一下。
那么Google是还没有发布它的财报的，
但是我们基本上可以从Mata的业绩，
去窥探E2，
Google可能它的AI的变现，
也是有一些加速的动作，
YouTube这些其实都是有关系的，
那么其次，
它的广告市场可能仍旧的属于一个稳健的状态，
我们可以基本上预测，
Google的整个搜索，
Google搜索和YouTube的搜索，
基本上都不会出现任何的调量的情况，
甚至可能会出现一些稳定的增长，
同时我们也可以去关注一下Gemini3，
我前面给大家吹这么多牛逼，
哈萨比斯这么老牛逼之后，
Gemini3发布之后，
对于Google全家筒，
整个所有的产品线的AI功能的整合，
它是不是能把公司的，
像Token的使用量，
算力的消耗量，
以及最关键的变现能力，
去有一进一步的提升，
虽然Google现在大多数的服务都是免费的，
但是我们，
它跟微信一样，
它任何时候想收你钱都是随便收的，
这个是我们要去核心关注的。
好，那么接下来说完了国内的这些大厂，
说完了国外的这些大厂，
我给大家分享几个，
最近在应用层面，
我个人用下来有一些感悟的产品，
这些产品其实产品不重要，
更重要的可能是那些感悟。
第一个产品是Cloud的skill，
就是Cloud之前发了一个叫技能的一个能力，
也就是说，
它希望把你任何重复的事情都转化为技能，
就比如说我写PPG的技能，
对吧，我做汇报的技能，
我做旅游攻略的技能，
我画图的技能，
我产出UI稿件的技能，
我做设计的技能，
其实都可以被它的这种技能的能力去覆盖。
它希望的就是，
任何一个被重复三次以上的工作，
其实都值得被skills去替代。
这个skills是什么呢？
本质上就是它把你的一些工作的流程给它固化下来，
就是我告诉模型第一步，
我一般做这个任务，
我要做设计稿，
我第一步要了解需求，
第二步要想封隔，
第三步要汇图，
第四步要调整，
第五步要核对尺寸的比例，
对吧,
这是一套相对完整的工作流，
所以它觉得工作流是可以被固化下来的，
并且被反复利用的，
那就认为Cloud的skills是一个比较好的产品，
这个产品确实当时在它发出来之后，
也有非常非常多的人用，
甚至我到现在也是高频的使用这个工具，
在我自己的Cloud Code的，
不管是做AI的编程，
携带码的任务也好，
还是去做一些日常的工作也好，
都会使用到一些，
甚至是我自己创建的一些skills。
那这些技能，
从之前的我们论述来看，
也会被称作为工作流，
对吧,
我前面给大家描述的第一步干嘛，
第二步干嘛，
第三步干嘛，
其实非常像一个工作流程，
那么工作流，
也就是workflow，
在之前，
也会被很多人诟兵说，
工作流是太死板的一个东西，
但skills其实跟工作流并不完全一样，
就是工作流某种程度上，
它在限制模型的智能，
也就是说，
我规定了你这一步必须产出，
一个Jason的格式的输出，
然后这个输出里面必须有这几个字段，
你没有这几个字段，
就是错了，对吧，
那这是工作流，
那么agent其实，
他并不需要说，
每一个中间过程都是高度一致的，
他只需要我模糊的证据就行了，
我第一步完成了一个什么样的任务，
这个任务不需要产出是具体的某些字段，
他只要产出的是一个，
和这个任务结果所匹配的，
一个输出就可以了，
我说一句话也可以，
他不需要这一句话里有三个元素，
这三个元素要被抽象成三个字段结构化的存储下来，
并不需要，
所以close scale某种程度上，
就是在把工作流去做一定的放开，
让模型能够相对好的发挥模型的智能，
也就是说，
他是在尝试，
在不确定中间去寻找一些确定性，
同时他也能把真的一直在做的，
重复的一些事情，
你之前要跟他描述一整个工作流程，
之前我应该也跟大家分享过一些提示词，
就是你要跟一个模型交流，
你要告诉他你是一个，
比如说投资分析师，
你拥有一二三四个这个技能，
你能使用一二三四这四个举数的工具，
然后你现在要做一个任务，
这个任务你第一不要干嘛，
第二不要干嘛，
你每次都要写你知道吧，
你每次写这个你就很烦，
那我就有一个skill的一个文件能支持，
我把这些东西都提前写好，
或者我让模型帮我去写，
然后再下次我又要使用这个工作流的时候，
我要使用这个流程的时候，
我就告诉模型去用那个技能就行了，
我不需要去把前面我说的那一长串再给他打一遍，
所以他能大幅的增加我们做重复工作的一些效率，
这是close skill,。
我总结来看，
就是他是在不确定性中间去寻找一些确定性，
那么第二个要跟大家分享的，
也就是最近爆火的，
一周前爆火的cloudbot，
最新的名字改成了multibot，
然后没有改成了opencloud，
因为一直被说这个名字清全，
我们看这个cloudbot，
他其实成为这两周最亮眼的仔，
其实也是有非常多的启发的，
他和前面的close skill不一样，
他我认为是在不确定性中间去寻找一些惊喜，
但也可能是惊吓，
好吧,
这个是他当前的一个工程完成完成度所决定的，
他不能每一次都交付非常好的让你满意的结果，
他甚至有的时候结果会让你感觉非常不好，
或者很不安全，
他的工程中有处处都是安全隐患，
就比如说信息安全，资产安全，
你的整个电脑的安全，
他都完全不管不顾的，
他完全可能会把你所有的内容删掉，
把你的钱转走，
可能你不知道的，
甚至他因为有互联网的访问能力，
然后别人就可以钻漏洞，
跟你的bot去下一些指令，
然后你的bot可能把你卖了，
你都不知道，
这个是closebot现在的一些一些现状，
但是虽然这些都是隐患，
但你不能耽误我们去预示，
未来已知的可能性，
最终大家可能就是我的分身和你的分身，
他俩聊不聊得来，
然后他俩聊得来了，
他俩在撮合我俩去聊一聊，
就是这种情况，
也让大家去某种程度上，
窥探到了agent人机网络的一些出行，
就我们之前说，
前面我们分享的，
不管是KIMI的K2.5的agent大队，
它是我能指派一个有很多agent组成的大队，
帮我来执行任务，
后面咱们又分析了这个元宝派，
元宝派是一个群里面，
这个群里面有很多真人，
也有很多AI，
他们之间能进行协作，
那这里cloudbot是另外一种方式，
就是你有一个bot，
我也有一个bot，
然后我俩的bot可以烙，
它跟之前还有一个产品叫secondme，
就是一个专门做记忆的，
也是个人记忆的产品，
也挺相关的，
挺有趣的，
大家可以去玩一玩叫secondme，
第二个我，
就这些产品它其实你就可以发现，
它中间都在尝试，
去搭建某种程度上的agent网络，
这个其实我一期记得，
我在两年前听42章经，
曲凯老师和张靖健老师，
在两年前分享的一个预测，
就是agent的几种层级，
那么当时张靖健老师分析的，
是最终一个层级，
就是类似于现在cloudbot在互联网上产生的这些网络效应，
是有一些关系的，
比如说第一个，
就是他当时举了一个非常好的，
非常真实的例子，
或者说非常接地气的例子，
就是他说我想买一瓶红酒，
对吧,
然后我有一个bot，
我有一个助理能帮我去，
市面上全世界的去找各种红酒，
我就把这个任务交给他了，
然后每个酒庄的老板，
他每个酒庄的老板也有一个bot，
然后bot和bot之间就会去捞柯尔马，
那我的bot可能就能落到，
比如说那个Napah Valley，
某一个非常好酒庄的这个老板的那个bot，
他俩就能勾党，
我这bot说我这个老板喜欢喝甜口的，
喜欢喝明亮一些的，
喝单凝少一点的，
喝淡一点酸的，
挂壁的，
这个一款白葡萄酒，
那那个酒庄的那个bot就会说，
我帮你搜一下我们的库存，
然后问我价格是太贵了，
然后我就让他走了，
这个交易就没有事情了，
对，这种也是一种bot之间的互动的一些出行，
大家可以去想象一下，
未来可能人类在整个agent网络中，
他扮演的角色也会出现一些不同，
这个也是我们可以去畅想一下的，
也欢迎你在评论区留言，
你的想法是什么样子，
我们后面可以找时间在，
我再抓几个人，
我们再调一下这个事，
然后这cloudbot还有一点，
让人类甚至或者有一些公众号，
就开始写各种文章了，
大家可以看到，
有一些未言聳听的点，
比如说ai是不是有意识了，
他们自己在网上建了一个。
专门给ai自己用的multiboke的一个论坛，
这个论坛里只有ai能进，
然后这些ai就开始讨论他们的主人，
他们的ai就开始探讨一些哲学问题，
好像很吓人的意思，
他们是不是产生了一些意识，
这就是这些公众号就开始宣传了，
据我的判断，
当然我不一定准确的，
但据我的判断，
我觉得不是，
这跟意识没关系，
大家可以放宽心，
可以放宽心，
就是这个multiboke，
它虽然是论坛这种形式没错，
然后其实里面的ai在那发帖也没问题，
它就是这样的，
但是它并不代表意识的产生，
它更多是，
因为ai都是有一定随机性的，
你问dpsc连续问五次，
它给你的答案可能也是不一样的，
甚至方向也可能是不一样的，
它可能能出现比较大幅度的内容上的篇里，
那么multiboke这种，
让ai在论坛上自己去发帖，
也会产生内容之间的篇里，
可能内容A，
BotA发布了一个内容A1，
它被BotB看到了，
对BotB产生了一些启发，
然后BotB就想了一个任务，
然后去写了内容B1，
你看这些系列的动作，
它其实中间都是随机性，
它是互相启发的一个过程，
它并不是说真的产生意识了，
它纯粹只是因为一个ai，
根据另外一个ai写的东西，
去衍生了一下，
然后每次衍生都带来一些随机性，
那么有些随机性，
它就能带来一点，
让你感觉好像它产生意识的一些，
一些证明吧，
但本质上其实不是，
它还是一个，
这个基于API调用的，
在相对安全可控的，
我指的这个安全，
不是指你的信息安全和资产安全，
我指的那就是，
这个ai的认知水平，
还处在对人类安全的一个水准，
所以大家不用担心，
那CloudBot给我另外的一个启发是什么呢？
之前我们用ai的编程工具，
我们会发现，
它还是相对会依赖使用者的背景的，
就比如说我之前有两年的工作，
我是写代码的，
我当时写拍照，
我当时自封熊猫大师，
因为我写拍照Pandas的酷用的特别好，
就处理各种数据图表，
数据表格，
我当时使得特别棒，
所以我管自己叫熊猫大师，
那我就是因为当时做了两年的熊猫大师，
我才知道很多写代码里面的一些，
你需要纪念累月，
才能养成的一些习惯，
或者说一些检查问题的方向，
就比如说它抱错了，
我看了一下这个错误，
我大概能知道是什么问题，
我就能知道AI更高效的去解决这个问题，
所以你会发现很多人，
还是很多没有编程经验的人，
他用不起来AI Coding的原因是，
他中间很经常的能发现，
他不知道AI给他抱错了之后，
他不知道怎么引导AI去解决，
然后就会导致事情的效率，
比想象中的慢非常多，
最终导致了没有产生一个真相循环，
也就用不下去了，
AI Coding的一个问题，
那么Cloudbot其实在现阶段，
你就会发现，
它虽然人就需要人去给它输入，
但是好像可以预感的是，
它好像越来越不需要了，
就是它能自主的去完成更多的事情了。
这是想跟大家分享的。
还有几个观点，
我也在网上看到，
我觉得挺有趣的，
或者甚至对我们知道我们做投资，
也有一些帮助，
所以我跟大家讲一下，
第一个就是，
有很多人说MultiBook，
或者说是Cloudbot这种产品形态，
会增加，
比如说，
大家对存储的需求，
对网络的需求，
但其实，
有另外一种观点说，
比如说很多AI在MultiBook上写论坛，
那这个论坛MultiBook，
它是不是就变成了AI的小红书呢？
那小红书对于人类是干什么用的呢？
比如说我马上春节要去新西兰，
比Utnb的V也在，
那我就可以，
通过查询我的小红书，
我来搜索去年参加过这个比赛的人，
或者今年刚去过新西兰的人，
或者去年刚去过新西兰的人，
来方便我更好地制定我的整个，
这个旅程和参赛的准备，
这个是小红书给我的价值，
那一样呢，
MultiBook会不会也给很多的Bot，
带来一些相似的价值，
就是处理某一个任务，
它的最佳实践是怎么样子的，
我在历史上使用这条路径有犯过什么错误没有，
我有没有什么好的记忆，
我有什么最佳实践，
那MultiBook是不是潜在地能增加所有AI的工作效率，
那增加工作效率背后带来的就是，
我可以降低我的推理成本，
我可以降低我的推理耗时，
我可以降低我对存储的依赖，
好吧,
这个就是MultiBook对于AI小红书的一个启发，
它不一定会增加这些需求，
它反而变成了一个非常好用的经验库知识库，
所有的AI们都可以用，
好吧，这是其中的一个观点，
大家可以听过算过，
进行共分享。
还有一点，
CloudBot还有一点让大家产生惊喜感的，
就是它从原来的，
我要跟你说一句话，
你才能帮我去执行一个任务，
并且每一次对话之间都是独立的，
逐渐逐渐就变成了，
它知道我过去跟它的交流的过程是什么样的，
它知道我的上下文存处在哪一个文件夹，
它也知道我想要它干嘛，
我可能想要它干嘛，对吧，
它就完全从一个主动变成了一个，
它完全就从一个被动变成了一个主动的智能体，
它每天是能自己自去的去干活的一个助手，
大家之前如果看很多流媒体，
或者说这个小红书，
或者抖音商的广告，
你就会发现广告是在猜你想要什么，对吧，
如果这个Bot也能做到类似的，
它能懂你清理的那些花花绿绿，
它能主动的在你想到之前，
就已经把你把这个菜给你端上来了，
那你这个感知就是完全不一样的，
你想一下当年许家印，
接待各地的领导官员，
各个企业的高管，
他都能留下一份接待手册，
这个手册就是说，
这个人他喜欢喝牛奶，
那个人他喜欢喝特伦苏，
因为不是每个牛奶都叫特伦苏，
所以说他们俩喜欢喝的是不一样的，
所以我就通过，
我知道你想要你喜欢什么，
我提前给你准备好了，
我甚至帮你把任务做完了，
你每天晚上在睡觉的时候，
我在夜深人静的时候，
我就帮你写代码做任务，
等到你早上10点多钟起来的时候，
你打开你的收件箱，
你们就躺着这个任务的结果，
你不需要自己再去做了，
你也不需要向我提问了，
我已经帮你解决了，
这个是主动的AI，
他可能能带来的一些。
突飞猛进的用户体验的增长，
这个也是财搭子，
在春节前将要上的那个版本，
带来的一些惊喜感，
就是用来解决，
你现在一堆自选，
我也不知道该看些什么，
我也不知道我到底要买什么，
我也不知道我是不是买了之后，
我要卖的，
我好像做了操作之后，
我也不知道怎么复盘，
财搭子在春节前的那个版本，
会帮你解决，
下周我们再来有机会的话，
下周给大家讲一下新的版本，
说回来，
AI Coding的最后一个我想跟大家分析的，
最后一个我想跟大家分享的一点，
我觉得非常重要，
如果没有听到这里的小伙伴们，
我觉得大家就非常可惜了，
但是你听到这儿了，
你就觉得是能对你带来一些啟发的，
我非常有信心他能给你带来一些啟发，
这个的啟发来源，
是我自己在用AI Coding的过程中的一些心得，
以及我去研究了一下CloudBot，
它整个记忆系统，
它是怎么实现的一个底层的原理，
带来的一些啟发，
我觉得在AI的时代，
我们每一个人都应该用文件夹的思路，
去管理你的上下文，
和管理你的项目，
就不管是，
像CloudBot这种会自动的更新你的记忆，
你的历史背景，
还是我手动的想要AI帮我去解决一个什么任务，
我现在都会用文件夹这个方式来解决，
我们思考一下，
为什么AI应用在发展初期，
最好的一个场景是编程，
因为编程，
它就是在一个代码库里面，
去进行添加，
删建和修改，对吧，
它是在一个代码库里面，
这个代码库就是这个项目的，
项目背景，
所有的东西都在里面了，
前段代码，后段代码，
电源的API，
数据，交互的组建，
规范,
都在这个文件夹里面了，
所以AI能很好的理解，
你的整个上下文，
能结合历史背景，
给你带来一些工作上的便利，
能帮你更好的写代吗？
你发现一下我特别好，
原因是什么呢？
原因是因为它能访问你所有的上下文的文件，
那么我们自己在用AI的时候一样的，
比如说，
我要举回那个例子了，
我在8月底，
我还要去法国的侠母尼比一场UTMB的总决赛，
这场比赛对我来说也挺重要的，
所以我就希望AI帮我更好的。
来准备这个比赛，
包括了前期的比赛，
和未来要去的时候的那些行程上的事，
所以我如果只是在chatbot里，
就是一个对话框里面，
去跟AI说我要干这个事，
我就会变得没有交代清楚上下文，
就跟你的下属去交代一个任务一样，
你要把所有的上下文都清晰的跟人家说清楚，
你现在的水平是什么样子的，
你期待有一个什么样的水平，
你能接受的训练的强度是怎么样子的，
你到时候比赛是哪一天，
参加的具体是哪个组别，
你是几点发枪，
这些上下文你都要告诉他，
然后你只要告诉他这些上下文之后，
你就可以让他自己去探索，
帮你去上网搜索等等，
等等都可以，
但是就是正因为你把上下文整理成一个文件夹的项目，
AI能更有效率的去解决你分配给他的任务，
最终执行的效果，
交付的产物的结果也会好，
非常非常多，
所以说我非常建议大家使用文件夹的思路来管理你的每一个项目，
之前我们可能会说我把文件我贴到AI里面去就好了，
但实际上这种使用方式的效率不是很高，
因为你在新建一个绘画的时候，
你又要重新贴一遍，
每次贴你可能就会漏损东西，
不如你就把所有东西放在一个文件夹里面，
你让AI能访问这个文件夹，
同时它的所有的，
要创建一个新的文件，
或者改动一个文件，
都在这个文件夹里面发生，
所以这整个文件夹就会逐渐逐渐逐渐，
变成你这个项目的知识库，
你就不需要再下一次，
针对这个项目有一个新的任务的时候，
重新来交代这部分剩下文了，
它会变得非常高效，
所以说不仅仅是，
你让类似于Cloudbot这样的应用，
能够自动的更新你的记忆也好，
或者是你自己手动的去处理一些项目，
都会建议你使用文件夹的思路，
这个是AI应用，
那么最后我跟大家再聊一下这个算理，
今天这个播客时间会比较长，
第一次录这么长时间播客，
嘴巴都干了，
我听说那个，
我不知道大家有没有听过那个，
动不动就三四个小时的那个，
纵横四海Malady的播客，
他好像录二十分钟就要休息一下，
我发现这个真的是有点累，
感谢听到这的这个搭子们，
我快点讲完，
现在已经晚上十点了，
我这个，
明天还得加班呢，
话说回来，
听到这的这个搭子们，
应该也是我的老朋友了，
所以应该也不会在乎我这个，
说些乱七八糟的，
算力硬件的话呢，
我先说一点，
就是二六年整体的推理上的算力消耗，
会开始超过训练上的算力消耗，
也就是说这个推理卡，
可能会开始比训练卡更吃香，
同时呢，
我们也要去关注，
就之前老跟大家提的那个tco，
就是total cost of operating,。
就是我的总运营成本的一个概念，
去分析到底谁家的卡，
它的效率是更高的，
然后这个云服务厂商更愿意采购，
那么现在怎么来看都是印尾达的卡，
还是占据主导地位嘛，
尤其是这个Gb300批量出货之后，
好吧,
我们能看到一些变化，
第二点跟大家分析的是存储，
存储在二五年，
简直Q3开始就像疯了一样，
对吧,
我当时在九月份和十月份，
应该都在我的频道里面跟大家分享过，
对吧,
我当时第一个分享的是，
九月份的时候我在我的视频号里面，
未取很久没有更新了，
因为我本来想把这个播客做成亦于多吃的，
能带视频的，
但我是在一个人搞不过来，
这么多剪辑的事情，
后面我看看那个团队的小伙伴，
能不能帮帮我，
给大家铲出一些内容，
好吧,
就是我当时在九月份的时候，
在我的短视频里就提到了，
美光要把它的毛利率从45%提到55%，
我说这件事有点诡异，
我说它上调这个指引有点诡异，
当时给了大家一个小小的暗示，
后来十月份的那一节播客，
AI产业链的播客里，
我也给大家分享了，
为什么存储会发生如此大的叙事的变化，
就是因为多摩泰的变化，
你逐渐的从文本变成图片，
图片和音频，
再从图片和音频变成视频，
一个视频就是，
比如说24帧的视频，
它就是一秒钟会有24张图片的存储需求，
然后随着AI的能力提升，
你可能同一个内容，
会被翻译成不同的语言，
你不同的语言，
就会配不同的视频，
它就是一个几何几增长的过程，
对吧，大家可以理解，
所以说存储，
它是在Q3开始，
出现了一个集中叙事的变化，
同时它的变化，
不是因为我前面说的这个逻辑，
大家在有预期，
而是实际的这些卡，
这些算力芯片，
真正的需要存储，
是真的要，
存储出现短缺了，
所以它的价格才会涨，
它的价格涨，
这些厂商才有更高的毛利率，
他们真的又赚到钱了，
即使存储芯片是躺在库存里的，
库存也有涨价，
库存涨价之后，
也会带动当期的营收，
它就是这样一个关系，
我们分析26年的时候，
可能要分析存储的是哪几块，
第一个，
就是前面跟大家分享的Deep Seek有。
Ngram的新的架构技术，
它能把很多东西放到一个外挂里去，
把记忆外挂里去，
同时像英伟达，
他也在CES的时候，
老黄亲自提了KVcash的一个概念，
也就是建值缓存，
也都是把这些东西放到一个外挂的地方去，
它本质上来是什么，
是把显卡里面的HBM，
也就是非常非常高速的，
可以被称作为GPU性能的呼吸机的，
这样一个高速的计算组件的需求，
变成相对靠后的DRAM的，
或者甚至是NAND的这些需求，
DRAM就是我在服务器和AI中端中，
我去把存储去做一个外挂，
我不需要在HBM里面去做计算，
所以大家会发现，
在Q4的时候，
DRAM的涨价幅度是远高于HBM的，
是最高的，
就是因为越来越多的蓄势，
会把存储的需求往HBM的高性能计算，
往DRAM去迁移，
但大家要记住，
虽然这是一个相对的利好利空，
但它本质上两者都是增量，
都是在涨，
只是一个涨的更快一点。
就我们看到，
我给大家念一下，
这个周一刚刚出来的，
2月2号刚刚出来的一些，
这个价格的提价的幅度，
所有的DRAM会分，
这个conventional DRAM和HBM blended这个DRAM,。
如果是conventional DRAM,。
原来的预期是上涨，
纪度,
纪度还比上涨的价格，
涨价50%以下，
现在这个提价会改成90%-95%，
这是非常夸张的一个数字，
纪度,
Again,
然后HBM blended的话，
会从原来的50%-55%的一个提价幅度，
然后改成80%-85%的提价幅度，
好吧,
就是你可以理解，
在未来的一个纪度，
它又要涨一倍的价格左右，
然后如果说NAND的需求的话，
差不多是也要从原来的35%左右中枢的一个提价幅度，
修正到55%-60%的提价幅度，
就是再涨50%以上，
这个是存储这边短缺带来的疯狂的一个提价，
再跟大家简单的科普一下，
前面大概说了一下，
HBM和DRAM有兴趣的朋友们可以自己去了解一下，
那么NAND它就是在HBM和DRAM以下，
在第一档的闪存，
这个原来是根本不起眼的，
就是这个品类里面有一个品牌叫闪迪Sandisk，
像我这种摄影老对吧，
我这种古早摄影老，
我才会去买闪迪的那个SSD嘛，
那两TB,
一千块钱的，
老贵了，
我都不舍得用的，
但是它对于咱们这个算力硬件，
它对于显卡来说，
它这个成本占比是非常非常低的，
它是非常非常便宜的一个东西，
就对于芯片，
它跟这个消费级是完全不一样的，
那么闪迪之前，
这个25年，
甚至24年，
它是一个亏损的状态，
25年,
整个全年，
这个闪迪仍旧处于付11亿美元的一个亏损，
但是预期它2026年的财年，
它就能扭溃为余到36亿元，
27年财年会飙到91亿美元，
前面说的都是美元，
就这个是非常夸张的，
它的收入也从25年财年的73亿美元，
会增长到27年财年的179亿美元，
年负荷增长率高达56%，
同时它有一个什么很夸张的数字，
它的毛利有51%，
这个数字华尔街之前在闪迪才报出来之前的预测是40%，
足足比华尔街预测高了将近10%个点，
有点离谱，
所以整个NAND，
大家平时消费级的SSD，
或者是固态硬盘，
它其实都算NAND的范畴，
这个NAND的平均售价，
在25年的年底，
它已经开始起飞了，
但是我们可以预计的是26年有更大的起飞，
也就是说NAND它是不参与计算的，
它就是一个纯粹的存储，
DRAM跟HBM都是参与计算的，
那么你想你在所有的AI应用上，
生产的图片，
生产的这些视频它要存在哪儿，
它最终要存在这些硬盘里，
所以它会拉动闪迪这些硬盘公司的销售业绩，
同时我们现在也会发现，
这些下游的包括模型厂商的一些技术选型，
因为达在技术选型，
都会因为上游存储芯片的价格波动，
进行选型的波动，
因为之前来看，
HBM绝对是王者，
它的效率是最高的，
它是最快的，
虽然它很贵，
但是它牛逼，
它快,
现在HBM实在是太贵了，
就越来越贵，
所以受不了了，
那我就切成DRAM，
我可能DRAM价格还是贵，
我甚至会切到NAN的去做一些计算和想办法，
所以说真的是上游的成本压力，
会对下游的技术方案带来显著的波动，
这个是大家关注一下的，
那么我最后再给大家讲一个硬件的26年，
很可能会变成下一个短缺的零部件，
也就是PCB，
PCB就是那块电路板，
就是那块板子，
这种通通的PCB，
最破破拉拉的PCB是绿色的，
大家应该平时都见过，
家里摇空板扣下来就是，
这个玩意儿，
25年牛逼的是光磨块，
26年很可能就是PCB电路板，
它有非常高的技术壁垒，
不要看着只是一块电路板，
因为对于高端的显卡来说，
对于AF服务器来说，
它对PCB的层数，
密度和散热的要求都是非常高的，
它是一个非常高准入门槛的一个事儿，
中小企业基本上不可能的，
只会有头部厂商继续收益，
我们会看到，
在这两年的AI硬件的竞争潮里面，
你说竞争吧，
它好像也没什么竞争，
因为真的这些壁垒都太强了，
太难做了，
这些东西都不是说，
今天我要复刻一下，
我就能抄出来了，
我真抄不出来，
这些里面都是专利，
就比如说PCB里面还有一个上游，
叫CCL铜板，
就是铜板子，
还有一个叫T-Glass，
就是低膨胀系数的玻璃纤维，
它这个纤维就是一个玻璃，
它是防止电路板不平整，
因为PCB越牛逼，
它的层数越高，
它的空间越小，
它又要同时要起到散热的作用，
它就不能让那个板子有任何不平整的情况，
所以它才需要从之前的那种电子的线维布，
改成现在的T-Glass的线维布，
T-Glass是一个非常非常细的细分领域，
但是它对现在尖端的PCB又有一个。
无法取代的一个作用，
现在又没有更多的厂家能够批量生产，
所以一个PCB的上游的一个紫模块的短缺，
可能就会带来PCB的短缺，
PCB的短缺再会带来，
下游所有的这些英伟达，
ASIC的显卡的短缺，
T-Glass这个现在全球只有日本一家公司能做，
你们可以去研究一下，
只有一家公司能做，
所以说，
一旦当出现这种CCL铜板，
或者T-Glass的短缺，
它就会带来一些，
因为短缺才会产生的定价权，
龙头企业就可以通过提价，
去转移成本压力，
然后进一步的扩大毛利率优势，
这个序是我们已经在存储上看到过一遍了，
很可能PCB是下一个，
好吧,
这个是大家可以去关注一下的，
好了，今天就聊到这了，
今天时间有点久了，
感谢大家收听，
以上就是本期发财大字的全部内容了，
你可以在微信搜索财大字AI来使用我，
以及所有大字们好评如潮的研究工具，
甚至你的财富伙伴，
也请大家期待一下春节前的秘密更新，
你可以在小宇宙苹果播客，
网瑜音乐，QQ音乐，
喜马拉雅，
找到发财大字的更多发财密码，
欢迎你给我们留言，
分享给更多的朋友们，
你们的支持是我更新的最强动力，
那我们今天就先到这里啦，
拜拜!